This episode is sponsored by no one actually.
But we do want to use this time here at the
top of the episode to let you know that there
is some brand new Journey to the Microcosmos
products available at DFTBA.com.
We’ve got a new tardigrade shirt either
in white or in blue and from now until the
end of August, we’ll be taking pre-orders
for them, and whichever color sells the most
will continue to live on in our store, while
the other will go away forever.
So, if you want to get your color of choice,
head on over to the link in the description
between now and the end of August to pre-order
your tardigrade shirt.
Nostoc are a genus of cyanobacteria known
for gathering their thin, thread-like bodies
into gelatinous colonies, forming what look
like, basically, a weird noodle soup.
Of course you might not want your bowl of noodle
soup to be bright green like this, and that is fair.
But outside the world of imagined meals, the
color of cyanobacteria like nostoc are an
indicator of their life-sustaining ability,
turning their chlorophyll into a vivid display
as they reflect green wavelengths into our
vision.
Then, with a flick of a switch, we can change
the light on our sample from white light to ultraviolet light.
And everything changes.
Our soup of filaments is now a bright, bright
red, like we just doused our noodles in hot sauce.
To be clear, there were no filters involved
in changing the color of the chlorophyll molecule.
And we did not add any kind of chemical to
make the nostoc glow red.
The nostoc is making that light.
All we did was flip a switch, and electrons
did the rest.
What the nostoc are doing here is fluorescing.
And as you will see today, they are not the
only organisms who can do this.
Throughout this video, we’re going to be
showing you different organisms, first under
white light, and then under one of the more
narrow bands of light that are part of our
new fluorescence microscopy toolkit.
Fluorescence is what it looks like when light
makes electrons jump around in their orbitals.
Inside an organism there are many, many chemicals,
and inside those chemicals are atoms and bonds
and electrons arranged in a way that makes
life possible.
Now depending on the structure of those atoms
and bonds, sometimes certain wavelengths of
light will excite the electrons, sending them
jumping up to a higher energy state.
But those electrons will very quickly fall
back down to their original state.
And when they do that, those electrons release
photons.
And that light is what we’re seeing here,
the emission light--bright against a dark
backdrop, while a filter blocks the original
excitation from obscuring the sight of our
organism fluorescing.
When a chemical is able to produce fluorescence,
it’s called a fluorophore.
And for our nostoc and other photosynthetic
organisms, we know that the fluorophore glowing
red under UV light is chlorophyll.
But we know this only because we know enough
about the cyanobacteria’s biology and chlorophyll’s
fluorescence to narrow down the source.
For other organisms, the source of the fluorescence
is a mystery to us, though with the right
combination of tools and experiments, we might
be able to narrow down the source4.
When we see this fluorescence, we know something
exciting is happening in our organism, we
just don’t know exactly where it’s coming
from.
The only clue we have is the color orange.
And since there are all sorts of possible
fluorophores in the world, we don’t even
know if there’s even just one molecule making
this light.
We might be watching several fluorophores
at work here, their excited electrons lighting
up the organism in unison.
Now fluorescence is when organisms take in
light and then reemit it a different wavelength.
But some organisms can make their own light.
And perhaps the most famous glowing residents
of the microcosmos are the dinoflagellates,
whose bioluminescent light you can sometimes
see across the surface of waves.
That light is not from fluorescence.
It is the result of a molecule called luciferin,
which emits light when it’s oxidized by
the luciferin enzyme.
This is a chemical process rather than a physical
one.
The effect is similar to fluorescence: a glimmer
of incandescent light coming from within a microscopic body.
But the cause is entirely different.
Dinoflagellates are bioluminescent, their
light is the result of chemicals reacting with one another.
Chlorophyll and other fluorophores, however,
don’t require another chemical to light up.
They just need the right wavelength of light
to hit them.
They then use that light to make light.
But while bioluminescence and fluorescence
are different phenomena, biology loves to
muddy the boundaries between the categories
we assign to things, and there are moments
where these two seemingly distinct phenomena
are in fact linked together.
Off the west coast of North America, there’s
a bioluminescent jellyfish called Aequorea
victoria, which shines blue when calcium activates
a molecule called aequorin.
But the light from that reaction is able to
provide energy to another protein, a protein
that fluoresces green when hit by that light
and it gives the jellyfish a somewhat more verdant hue.
When scientists found this protein, they gave
it the very literal name of Green Fluorescent Protein, or GFP.
But there’s nothing wrong with a name that
cuts right to the chase like that, especially
when you’re naming what has since become
one of the most famous fluorescent proteins.
The beauty of fluorescent proteins like GFP
goes beyond just the colors they show us under the microscope.
They have allowed scientists new ways to illuminate
organisms from the inside, to introduce fluorescent
proteins through stains or genetic engineering
into an organism like a fluorescent molecular marker.
And from there, the fluorescence helps us
map out the events inside a cell that might
otherwise be invisible, like the dynamics
of gene expression or the course of a cell’s fate.
Often, when you see those stunning images
of cells awash in a rainbow haze, you’re
looking at the careful work of decades of
science, of the lessons we’ve learned from
nature about how to see it in a new way.
And as we apply these lessons, it’s important
for us to make sure we give the organism’s
their due for the fluorescence made of their
own structures--like the red glow of the Nostoc’s
chlorophyll, which we call autofluorescence.
But it’s not simply a matter of giving credit.
In one form, autofluorescence illuminates,
providing us with another way to see the molecules
of an organism at work.
The autofluorescence of chlorophyll can, for
example, tell us more about the health of a plant.
Yet in another form, autofluorescence obscures.
If we introduce our own fluorescent markers
into a cell, only to find that the cell’s
own molecules produce a light similar to our
markers’, the colors become very difficult to interpret.
And so the usefulness of autofluorescence
ultimately becomes decided by its context.
For the scientist, it is a consideration as
experiments are planned and interpreted.
For the organism, it is simply a reaction
in its own body: a light made into new light,
a color made into new color.
And for us, it is a glimmer of something new,
made by old friends.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We recently celebrated a couple of milestones
here on this channel.
Our two year anniversary as a channel was
back on June 24th, and our one hundredth episode
was uploaded on July 12th.
So, to celebrate, and also just because we
had a lot of fun hanging out the last time
we did this, we’re going to have another
livestream here on the channel this Wednesday, July 28th.
So, if you have any questions you’d like
us to answer during that stream you can leave
them in the comments below, or in the chat
during the stream.
We hope to see you there!
Like we mentioned at the beginning of this
episode, we also have some brand new Tardigrade
shirts that are available for pre-order at
DFTBA.com.
So, visit the link in the description if you
want to make sure you get your color of choice.
And while you’re there you can also check
out some of our other products like these
paramecium socks and even our Journey to the
Microcosmos coloring book.
The folks you’re seeing right now on the
screen, they are our Patreon patrons.
If you, watching right now, are one of those
people, allow me to say thank you on behalf
of this entire Microcosmos team and also on
behalf of the people who are able to get this
content because you have helped support us.
If you would like to join these folks in being
a patron of Journey to the Microcosmos, you
can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram or on TikTok.
And if you want to see more from us, there
is always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.